[Music]
we all know anything can happen out
there sometimes we feel
lost we push and we suffer on we keep
going that makes all the
difference hey what happened to you boy
you don't look so good meatball look
somebody likes my meatballs play PAW
Patrol we got a race to win just
remember Michael this race doesn't
Define you I raced for 19 years this is
my last chance to win 3 2 1 there's a
young boy living in the city all they do
was run run R over the next 10 days
these athletes will cross 400 miles
climbing biking and kaying that dot is
Daddy go Daddy
D let's talk I gave the meatball 3 days
and 200 miles ago lead the stupid dog
and let's go come on move dumb dog what
is it
boy oh oh God can't believe I almost
walked right off that Cliff extra
meatballs for you my
friend he's hurting what do you think he
went through before he met us whatever
it was it wasn't good how the hell did
he get all the way from here to there
while we were on bikes and zip lines and
running and climbing he must have wings
we don't know about good boy you know
I'm back like I never left you want to
start to erase the buckets of pain I
need a bigger bucket team broad rail has
traveled over 200 miles and they've
found a companion Daddy has the dog what
have you done think you found your new
partner in suffering Michael yeah he's
the king I think we should call him
Arthur Arthur the
king how's he doing he's been through so
much this book needs a vit I don't want
you going to hurt
anymore he's a
fighter just like
youor famous dog looks even worse than
the rest of you maybe you all deserve
each other always underestimated aren't
my
buddy this isn't the route on the map
it's okay just follow Arthur lead the
way
[Music]
King I've never seen anything like this
everybody knows about
it guess what I'm not a dog
[Music]
person